[Musique]
et c'est avec Anthony Saint-Léger qu'on
en parle on sort Anthony bonsoir les
amateurs de théories du complot et les
contes prorus en raffole ses accusations
récurrentes de mise en scène de la gare
en Ukraine après les fratrus du 10
octobre des faux blessés selon eux
auraient ainsi joué la comédie dans les
rues de Kiev qu'en est-il et bien
regardez c'est images que l'on va
découvrir ensemble on y voit un couple
en 100 et notamment cette femme qui doit
attirer l'attention on la voit avec un
bandage que lui met le soldat et on la
voit surtout prendre son téléphone et ce
elle filmait entouré de plusieurs
journalistes et puis vous le voyez un
bâtiment qui semble avoir été frappé par
une explosion alors de nombreux médias
audiovisuels dont France 24 ont été
interpellés pour avoir diffuser cette
ces images cette vidéo la presse écrite
n'est pas épargnée on a par exemple ici
le français Libération l'italien coréen
delacera et l'américain Daily News qui
ont vous le voyez eu
femmes en une de leurs journaux pourquoi
ils ont été interpellés parce que pour
beaucoup qu'il a partagé notamment et
surtout des comptes prorus et bien il
s'agirait d'une comédie d'une comédie
faite pour les caméras de télévision et
c'est un des éléments principal de
l'argumentation c'est la phrase
prononcée par la femme dans la vidéo qui
nous dit prends une photo de moi André
André et vite je vais prendre une photo
et je l'enverrai à ma sœur en Russie
cette phrase elle a d'ailleurs été
soulignée par cette analyse politique
prorus qui parle de production drame de
photos dramatique faite pour les médias
occidentaux et quitte à l'origine de la
vidéo initiale de quoi faire renchérir
certains internautes propagande ne
guerres nous dit celui-ci ou encore
Steven Spielberg n'aurait pas fait mieux
chapeau elle les artistes nous 17 autres
alors quel est le contexte en réalité de
cette vidéo et bien on va revenir sur la
publication virale qui va en fait nous
donner un indice et en l'occurrence
c'est ce logo il y a ici une capture
c'est ce logo que l'on voit à droite
host West haust ouest c'est le nom d'un
média russophone à basé à Berlin médiac
a contacté la rédaction des Observateurs
de France 24 et qui nous explique qu'il
a repris une vidéo de l'agence EPI et
effectivement lorsqu'on le regarde la
base de données de l'agence en question
on retrouve la vidéo cette scène elle a
été tournée le 10 octobre le jour des
frappes russe donc à 10h34 très
précisément où ça acquieve et plus
précisément près du centre d'affaires de
la tour 101 la Seine elle a été tournée
ici très précisément et la tour 101
c'est ici c'est le bâtiment que l'on
voyait tout à l'heure dans la vidéo
virale cette photo et cette vidéo on la
doit à un journaliste un
photojournaliste et frame lukaski qui
travaille donc pour les IP qui a été
contacté par nos confrères de libération
et qui explique et bien ce qui s'est
passé et que André andré-a vite c'est
don que le nom de l'homme que l'on voit
sur la vidéo et cette femme et cet homme
ont été blessés par des éclats de verre
pour ce qui est de la rédaction des
Observateurs de France 24 maintenant
elle a contacté un autre journaliste en
l'occurrence travaillant pour Reuters
qui lui explique aux observateurs de
France 24 que la scène a donc bien eu à
Kiev près de ce centre de d'affaires de
la tour 101 et plus précisément il nous
explique que c'est parce que justement
les journalistes ont vécu ce
bombardement cette explosion de près
qu'ils se sont précipités sur les lieux
du drame ce qui explique donc il y a eu
beaucoup de photographes de journalistes
au même moment au même endroit et en
présence des mêmes victimes et en
l'occurrence cette femme donc soignée
par un soldat
ukrainien des récits et des images qui
vont confirmer l'authenticité de la
scène et la réalité des victimes non
déplaise donc aux accusateurs réguliers
de mise en scène il y a d'autres
accusations de mise en scène qui visent
cette fois le président
effectivement le président qui on le
sait c'est fait remarquer depuis le
début du conflit par ces interventions
filmées notamment depuis divers endroits
de la capitale qui est diffusée sur les
réseaux sociaux et depuis le 11 octobre
plusieurs comptes pro à Kremlin publie
cette photo sur fond vert de volodi
mirzeninski entouré vous le voyez d'un
matériel vidéo preuve selon eux qui le
publieraient ces vidéos donc non pas
depuis le terrain mais depuis un studio
et pour certains même il serait à l'abri
à l'étranger c'est ce que sous-entend
cette internaute depuis un fond vert en
Pologne nous dit-il en anglais nous
avons par exemple cette publication qui
nous explique que c'est une propagande
impressionnante digne de Hollywood
d'autres comptes ont publié cette
séquence vidéo d'une cinquantaine de
secondes où l'on voit effectivement le
président
volodingski parler ce qui semble être
finalement les coulisses d'une captation
vidéo on
une interview il y a aussi des membres
de ce qui semble être une équipe
technique et puis vous le voyez ces
images de vos lodimir à zellenski
retoucher par ordinateur en tout cas
retravailler des images qui s'aiment le
doute mais qui sont sortis de leur
contexte et pour cause leur lorsqu'on
fait une recherche d'images inversée et
bien on retrouve plusieurs articles et
plusieurs publications relatifs à cet
événement on est en fait en juin dernier
en juin 2022 le président volody Meers
selenski elle s'exprime à l'occasion de
sommet liés à la technologie à des
conférences tech donc par avec un
discours par hologramme et on retrouve
même une vidéo YouTube que je vais vous
montrer qui revient sur les différents
coulisses de la fabrication de ces
hologrammes et ces deux cette vidéo
d'ailleurs que sont extraites plusieurs
images accusatrices que l'on a vu tout à
l'heure alors il n'est pas possible pour
autant de dire que volody mirzelenski
n'a jamais utilisé de fond vert pour ses
interventions mais les images que l'on a
vu tout à l'heure ne sont pas une preuve
deux trucages et d'ailleurs et j'en
terminerai là-dessus c'est accusations
de trucages et de mise en scène sur les
interventions du Président ukrainien
sont un refrain assez lancinant depuis
le début de l'intervention russe
notamment évidemment à part les progrès
merci beaucoup Antony pour cette
chronique info intox restez avec nous on
se retrouve dans quelques minutes pour
un nouveau journal Paris direct continu
[Musique]